i'm so happy that i get to talk about it  me and toby snuck into a theater  together like on opening night and just  watch with my baseball cap on my mask no  one knew we were there three spider-men  across universes are sharing a frame  together and your hair your little head  just explodes the fact that i get to be  one of those people wearing the suit  next to my actual spider-man hero toby  maguire and the brilliant incredibly  talented funny good sweet perfect  spider-man of tom holland and that i get  to be the middle brother and we were  just there to kind of support and have a  lot of fun and it was so much goddamn  fun would you do it again do you would  you put the suit on if given the  opportunity i'm open of course i'm very  very old it's always going to be a part  of me whether i'm playing in the  character or not i feel very connected  to him but but it would have to be very  very special and fun